,
The main role of the immune system is to avoid damaging agents
which fall into our body, and the role of this system is their destruction
These harmful agents are part of the harmful proteins
which can do damage to your body, viruses, bacteria, and even
eukaryotic parasites, as well as fungus.
So all these agents, if they got into your body,
would cause any form of disease.
All of these agents are generally called pathogenic agents.
,
So the basic role of the immune system is, in the first line of the front
with this agent gone - and if so
get into your body to kill them and eliminate them
from our system so that we do not get sick and with that
let us not die.
I just mentioned that there are two fronts
defense and apart from them are also
kind of subclassifications.
First Defense Front - I'll call it the first line
which essentially plays the role of eliminating everyone
these pathogens.
And here we mention
Lekuren tone.
Our skin keeps the pathogens away from entering the body
the skin also has higher acidity that makes it difficult
the introduction of certain types of bacteria in such an environment.
You also have mucosal membranes, where in the mucus
there are some chemical substances that they can not
bacterial survival.
For example, you find the acidic environment
in your own juice.
,
You might think that the stomach is not your outer part but,
in essence it is.
Your entire digestive tract, for which you will also take video
in a near future, is in your outer part
You can imagine the body of most vertebrates
as a pretzel in which the digestive system
is the inner part of this gevreku.
So the juice of the stomach is in the outer space of our body and
and you can imagine that this environment is lenient for the pathogens
to survive.
So this is the first line of defense, but as far as we know it
this is not enough, and that some of the pathogens can
to get into our bodies, and here we have to start thinking
for the second line of defense.
what happens when we have presence of these pathogens in our body
,
And as in the first and second line, I'm talking
for non-specific immunity - and that makes sense
then when we start talking about immunity
specific.
So these two are non-specific.
,
And when I say the non-specific expression
born - it means that we generally have a response
in those ages that are perceived as damaging.
and have no memory for the agencies with whom they have come into contact with before
It does not respond to a specific type of virus
means the answer to each type of virus
or each type of bacteria, but they do not know it
that this is type A, B, C or that is bacteria A, B, C
They just perceive it as a virus and that's it.
Do not take it in or pull your neck
This is bacteria.
do not know what the bacteria is in contact with.
So this one is non-specific or
immune system born (natural)
We will also analyze the specific immune system in detail
because you can imagine, it's too much
complicated and interesting when you start thinking about it
storing viruses from your body, which the virus has been in contact with before
and consequently have the best response in contact with the virus
bread or protein.
so here we are talking about the non-specific immune system.
and the second line of your non-specific system,
they are great.
One, it is inflammatory remnants.
,
For this I will realize it in a special video, but in general.
all of us have experienced inflammatory responses.
When you see the blood leaking into a certain part
and see that there is pus - it will expose it
in more detail what the actual inflammatory response is
but what is happening
is the behavior of blood with combat cells
to fight off the infection that you have. I bring these components
in the place where we have an app cut where we have a lot
bacteria or whatever pathogens.
So the inflammatory response in general has to do with fluid behavior
and fighters to fight.
,
For this subject I will make a video in its own right.
But the result is that a piece of tissue or
part of your body inflates - a huge amount
of the fluid and by-products that is the result of the "battle" that occurs.
For this we will realize a special video.
The other line of defense that is and part of
inflammatory response - is phagocytosis or
phagocytes.
,
what I want to realize in the remainder of this video is
to speak a bit more in detail about phagocytes
because when we understand the function of phagocytes, it helps
in the best sense of the immune system
will also help us in the related topic
inflammatory response due to phagocytosis
are part of the inflammatory response.
Phagocytes are a type of cell
which are plagued by pathogens
Phagocytes also ingest other substances, but when they talk about
immune system, talk about pathogens.
Let's say that this is phagocyte.
This is phagocyte.
There is a kind of berthame
Skam for concentrated focus on the inner part of the phagocytes.
It's a eukaryotic cell, but what I want to do is
to see what happens when the phagocytes face a particle
foreign or with a bacterium.
Let's say this here is foreign bacteria.
From this phagocytic and this is what we said is non-specific.
what's up, possesses receptors that replicate us
the substances you know as damaging.
You can imagine being a kind of supersensor.
,
They are probably supersensors for bacteria.
Bacteria have proteins in their appearance
something like that.
Of course they do not look like that.
I'm presenting you in a Y and a triangle so that you can see it
fit between them.
At the moment these two link - let me present the script
when these two are connected between them.
So this is the bacterium.
This is a pathogen.
The same situation is with the virus or with the virus
any other agency.
we will see in our future videos that these cells
can be attacked by other molecules, which it does
that these phagocytes increase the level of assault.
As soon as you connect - this is the bacterium
Invasive pathogens
And now it's connected
and has stimulated the receptors in phagocytes
Phagocytes will start to gllabber - it will overwhelm you
this pathogen.
,
And these two parts will finally meet.
and when they meet, what's going to happen
Very fast bacteria will
is completely immersed.
And it will be inserted inside the cell.
And now the cell - as soon as you meet these two parts
will be melting the membranes, and this component will be located in
its small membrane flush - or you can imagine how it was
we blink her small.
So this is the pathogen, in this case the bacterium - but
phagocytosis - the process is entirely identical in the sense
of the globe of the agencies.
If it was a virus or any kind of foreign protein or
any kind of a foreign molecule - in fact,
not only to foreign agencies.
This process is also directed towards molecules that are not
foreign, but it is necessary to clean up.
But we will focus on the immune system, the agency says
foreign.
,
So this membrane here will completely dissolve and come to fruition
this agent in this form.
And of course, you have receptors and who knows
if they are still there.
Within time --- let's draw in order to see
which part is which.
As soon as it becomes globe, this complex is called
phage, which is actually a bladder which is in itself
the foreign agent to be eliminated.
While other bladders that contain substances themselves
which are the third of these phagosomes - to say
this is a bladder that contains substances - lysosomes
and contains reactive oxygen species.
,
And if it comes into contact with anyone
by biological components, will make a bull.
But at the moment the pathogen is melted inside
cell, this small compound will melt here and will
emptying its contents into the fagot, so in this bladder
which contains this pathogen, and then does its defect.
Essentially, it delivers its digestion.
The first role is the elimination and
murder.
and the second role - with this I will give
a little taste here.
This will be prefixed with details in our next videos.
It destroys.
,
So now we have complete destruction.
It means the agency is embedded in the constituent proteins and us
other molecules.
Then, what does phagocytosis do - is that
takes some of these molecules
the nodules of these proteins.
by doing away with them.
Proteins are simply a sequence of amino acids.
Normally when people say proteins, they talk
for long sequences of amino acids.
When talking about short sequences of amino acids
or for the proteins which are multiplied, they refer to as well
peptide chain.
The peptide chain is a short chain of amino acids.
So this type here will take some special peptide chains, some of them
the special part of the components that has already destroyed them, attaches to
some other proteins.
Now I will take a part of the bacteria
I will associate it with another protetine, which is called
the main complex of histocompatibility - and if we have the keyword
for phagocytes, this is the main complex of histocompatibility
types II.
,
It looks like a strange word, but we will find it
quite often.
,
And the abbreviation is FKH.
this is a protein that binds to this peptide which we
a form has been scratched or worn out by
this pathogen, then this phagocyt will present it
in its membranen.
So this combination - this complex of MHCs - in this
case, it will be the FKH II prothene protein.
,
For Type II we will talk in the future.
what is further the presentation of this complex in
his surface.
,
The reason why we are trying to elaborate this
process - you can say, but we are already present
we removed the agent and killed him.
What Sal is worried about what's being done with peptides?
This is crucial to our immune system, because we will see them
even the other components of the immune system.
Keep in mind, so far we are talking about non-specific immunity.
This guy here, he said, is a conqueror.
And do not know what kind of conqueror.
She says, let me connect to this and kill her.
It's one of those things I know to be foreign to my body.
And he kills, but the matter is that he leaves on his surface and
now specific parts, components that in reality have
memory and attach special components, you can say, giii, Zotni.
Fagocit, look, you've already killed something
Allow me if I have any specific reaction that I can
is initiated by this complex you are presenting.
For that, many phagocytes are also called
the antigen presenting cell.
,
We will go into details of what exactly is
is antigen.
I also call this pathogen agent.
The antigen in essence is - you can think of it as a protein
or a peptide chain that initiates it
immunological reaction.
I'll be a bit - the specific immune system.
and I will be a little more accentuated about it
I will - I will make a video for antigens and
but you can now see it as a chain
peptide.
Antigen is simply a protein or part of a protein.
So this makes the antigen presentation later on
may be perodrene from other parts.
Tashi, one thing is that there are many, many types
of phagocytes.
and how much I was informed - when you meet different words
do not fall into confusion by the different types of phagocytes.
I'll do a review now.
You have neutrophils.
,
These are the most common phagocytes.
and also by the answer, the number and the speed.
So get to the site of infection very fast.
Phagocytes do not necessarily have to be killing alone in this way.
I have the word, called phagocytes because they gllabber
in that form, but we will also talk about other forms in the following videos
so phagocytes can also release chemical substances or even DNA networks
to trap pathogens, but neutrophils
are fast and in large numbers.
Then you have the macrophages that are to a great extent
more versatile and carry big berries, but also
are phagocytes.
Then dendritic cells.
When you meet the dendritic cell keyword, you will think
hey, shit to do with dendrites
nervous system?
But no, nothing has to do with the nervous system.
,
The reason why they are called dendritic cells is because
they seem to have dendrites.
,
They look like neurons on a mass, but they do not
participate in the nervous system in any form.
And here they tend to be system activators
the specific immune we will talk about in the following videos.
Either way, I'll let you down here and talk more
for all this in some of the following videos.